here's the story it's a little past 10
p.m right now
and I was editing a movie reaction for a
couple I was a couple hours into the
edit and then um something went wrong
with my computer
and then I lost all the progress on that
edit
and I went
screw this
I'm gonna watch the whale I've been on
the to-do list I was like sure why not
it seems like a good time I've never
seen the trailer for this movie I've
heard great things about it specifically
that bread and Fraser is awesome in it
and I love Darren aronofsky's work I
know they can be quite sad and intense
I'm not sure exactly what the movie's
gonna fully uh entail or or be about uh
but the subject matter does sound
intriguing to me at least from the few
things I've heard about it I've told you
guys have been here as part of the
reject Nation for a while yeah I've been
in therapy for like a decade at this
point and you know a big part of a lot
of my therapy discussions has has
definitely been my struggles with body
dysmorphia I had it since I was a little
kid binge eating and using food as a
coping mechanism I've had some massive
Kuwait gains and weight losses over the
years it's a constant struggle every
time I'm on camera it's the first thing
I'm always thinking about myself as much
stomach even when I got stressed by that
I instantly get this urge to be like I'm
gonna go get Taco Bell or something like
that while I know this movie is not
going to be any anything like that at
least I imagine won't be necessarily
about that that was part of the
Intriguing part of the subject matter of
oh yeah a guy who uh uses like pretty
much harms himself with overeating and I
can relate to that to a certain extent
definitely not the degree of the makeup
effects that I've seen applied to burn
and Frazier but there's a part of me
that melee was like yeah I feel like I
could understand a decent amount of that
subject at least regardless you're gonna
throw that all out the window throw my
personal life out the window and just
watch this movie so with that in mind
Let's Escape leave a like uh subscribe
and click that notification Bell to get
notified when we got a reaction up on
this channel that might pique your
interest full interaction watch long so
you sync up with your own copy of the
whale I bought this off Amazon just now
available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page thank you to everyone who's
become a super sexy reject since
sincerely your support has been
exceptional without further ado
let's see what all the hype is about
[Music]
interesting is it in this aspect ratio
the whole movie it'd be good for
everyone to review the paragraph
structure PDF I sent you a few weeks ago
he's not on screen
and yes the camera on my laptop still
doesn't work
believe me you're not missing much oh
this title has always fascinated me
oh
geez
just use your key gosh are you okay
should I come on maybe that's actually
calling in
that's embarrassing do you have a phone
at my phone's dead I need to just read
it okay that the author is just trying
to save us from his own sad story this
book made me think about my own life and
then it made me feel glad
so he's the whale and the makeup is
incredible it's an essay
but why did you have me read it to you
because I thought I was dying and I
wanted to hear it one last time this is
Adara daronovsky movie he's probably
going to die shut up
what hush
you probably have really high blood
pressure man deep breath
he's got such a sincerity to his
performances man what was my blood
pressure
238 over 134. wow we that's
you must be from New Life why the hell
would you want to believe that the world
is about to end I believe that when
Christ returns it's going to be
beautiful yes
believe me he doesn't want to hear about
new life because it's caused him a lot
of pain
oh this guy's just gonna stick around
isn't he killed his boyfriend killed his
boyfriend what
he probably won't be here next week
where is he going
I'm sorry
put it together man you have congestive
heart failure if you don't go to the
hospital you'll be dead by the weekend
you will die
sounds like that's what he wants well
then I better get to work because I have
a lot of essays this week God damn it
I'm sorry
did you still want to hear about Christ
message of love and Savage no he does
not God I still don't understand why you
had me read that essay to you this is a
really good essay it's it's really this
has to be based on a play yeah
it has a has a real Play Rhythm I'm
sorry you say you're sorry one more time
I will shove a knife right into you I
swear to God go ahead What's it gonna do
my internal organs are two feet in at
least
[Laughter]
I have a good morbid sense of humor
please
that's sad
swatching your friend die thank you
oh man
that is [__] sad later they set out
on a ship captain by the pirate named
his entire life set grounds trying to
kill a certain whale we think this is
sad because whale doesn't have any
emotions
wow it won't help him at all this book
made me think about my own life
is ultimately the whale but he's also
the other characters
counting this week
I wonder why the choice to shoot it in
this aspect ratio
how long this is gonna last
thank you God this level of self-harm
does this mean I'm gonna get fat
so that's cool
you're a senior right you actually care
of course they care
so there is sweating his ass off I just
thought that maybe we could spend some
time with each other
time with you
this is
a terrible week you'd still be that
piece of [__] dad who walked out of me
when I was eight
all because he wanted one of his
students can I have one of these
yet she's here just thought that maybe
we can get to know each other
I don't even know I'm here oh he invited
her directly I can pay you
I can pay you how much can you pay me
everything I have
000 something like that I'd have to
check don't tell your mom
stand up and walk over to me I can't
really shut up
come over here
she is a commanding presence
yes
oh God
oh uh shuts that door doesn't even want
to give herself a second to feel sorry
for him
[Music]
yeah everyone just wants to check up on
him it measures perspiration it's an
indicator of stress here
I don't need a little machine to tell me
to take a few deep breaths and stop
sweating and sometimes you do though
was she here
you haven't seen her since she was eight
years old and you're gonna reconnect
with her by doing her homework for her
it's fine it's not fine you're gonna
help it is stress level
it doesn't look like she has any friends
I'm worried that she's forgotten what an
amazing person she is
fall
okay I have to go soon
trying to help but also enable very
interesting
nice to go
puke was brighter book oh oh my God are
you choking
[Music]
oh [__]
okay damn this guy could die at any
moment
seems like a guy who's made a lot of
mistakes in his life but it's
probably a decent guy underneath all of
it it's a really depressed one if you
say that Walt Whitman wrote song for
myself yeah
it's called A Song of Myself
my title is better
it's overwritten and dumb and repetitive
and and in reality he's just some
worthless 19th century
ouch that's an interesting perspective
it would make for an interesting essay
nah man you can't be honest something
with your harder than a homophobia part
is your mother
with anyone right now no
why are you interested
of course not I love their scene work
together man they're so good together
why'd you get all that weight
I don't if you're gonna interrogate me
I'm going to do the same thing
oh it's like he
did he do it intentionally someone close
to me passed away and it
it had an effect you had him over for
dinner once when Mom was in Montana
visiting Grandma uh
damn
how'd he die I don't I I really don't
want to talk about that right now
tell me what you really think
you want me to write what I really think
I'll be right back
in like 20 minutes
[Applause]
man the talking pool of Sadie sings
performance here it's got a lot of depth
underneath those eyes
kind of actor you could
feel what she's thinking and Brendan
Fraser is okay now he's phenomenal I get
all the hype
foreign
asked about the boyfriend you okay
yeah yeah fine I'm fine
who's outside are you his friends or his
daughter are you surprised
yeah I guess what's more surprising that
a gay guy has a daughter that someone
actually found this
song from New Life what I like about
religion is that it assumes that
everyone is an idiot and that they're
all incapable of saving themselves I
think they've got something right with
that you could write an essay I have
some pamphlets that I think
how did you just do that are you coming
back tomorrow I'm sorry what's happening
yeah what what are you doing I'm really
uncertain about that whole dynamic there
I have probably read everything new life
church has ever written that's great and
everything but these tracks are just the
beginning there's so much more in the
Bible that we can't I read the Bible
[Laughter]
God creates us expels us from Paradise
we wander around for thousands of years
killing each other before he comes back
and saves 144 000 of us meanwhile seven
and a half billion of us fall into hell
foreign
yeah that is perspective there's a
reason why I knocked on your door right
when you needed someone the most
isn't there any way I can help I mean it
seems like he needs someone the most all
the time well there's something you
could do for me I hope you know I wasn't
I'm not oh my God I'm pleased you gotta
believe me when I say I'm not attracted
to you you're a fetus
please just let me help
thank you
it's very helpful praise be to God
it's a fat guy wheelchair what would you
pay for this thing nothing we ordered it
for a patient a few months ago what
happened
they lost a lot of weight
good actually this is really nice
yeah it's great for him she got an
electric
where are you from
uh Iowa you're from Iowa and you came to
Idaho to do missionary work
he's dying
he's refusing to go to the hospital but
he needs is spiritual guidance
foreign
slide over my big brother did some
missionary work for New Life
went to South America dad had set it all
up pushed them into getting married to
the skull from the church he barely knew
practically arranged he met someone else
fell in love started a whole new life I
thought he was going to be able to get
over all that religious stuff but it was
like a cancer he
couldn't shake it it's a knee deep in
you man stop sleeping stopped eating
lost a ton of weight
this guy's out jogging on a bike path
here the river in Lewiston sees
something washed up on shore and that
was Alan
the love of Charlie's life and my
brother
oh
to this day my dad won't admit it
denying him
to the end
damn
in a few days he's probably gonna be
dead so what he needs is for you to
leave him alone I'm the only one who can
help him you understand me
wow
he managed to sneak up on their
conversation
actually I got another night shift
tonight I better uh
you good for the night
damn
bonded by the trauma
I mean they're probably bonded before
that but Alan's death just
unified them even more
yeah you can um
[Music]
Charlie
have a good night okay
just leave the [__]
Pizza
his apartment smells
this notebook is recorded I hate
everyone
#mood this uh Park and smells this
notebook is [__] I hate everyone
that the author was just trying to save
us from his own sad story
foreign
I hate everyone
forget about the poem write whatever you
want whatever you're thinking he's such
a sweet guy you know I was in a really
strange place in my life when I married
your mom ask
I understand that you're angry she's
hurt okay you know what you can't throw
me away like I'm a piece of garbage and
then suddenly just want to be my dad
eight years later
I'm glad because you taught me something
very important
people
are [__]
seems like they probably had a really
great relationship prior to all that if
you had all that money saved up and
wanted to be a part of my life so bad
you could have been sending money to Mom
I did
it could have been a part of my life
really
who would want me to be a part of their
life
foreign
acceptance and resolve I hope you know
what an amazing person you are
I couldn't ask
for a more incredible daughter
she has no idea he's died does she
is such an interesting history with all
the characters here
someone's outside again I like this
inclusion I always show the
shot of someone walking around in the
back is he okay I don't know I ground up
some Ambien and I put it in a sandwich
where did you get Ambien it's the
pharmacist
nice does this make you nervous because
it's just bought I know what pot is okay
no you only think you know what pot is
because your parents told you a bunch of
lies about it don't
i've smoked pot before oh oh I'm so
impressed I wasn't trying to impress
you've not smoked pot before yes I have
it
it was awesome it was kind of a problem
that is the stupidest thing I've ever
heard in my entire life
I had a problem you were a stoner you
had a hobby all right I'm gonna go just
tell him I was here you know you leave
I'll feed him the rest of the pills I
have in the bottle what wow it's like a
devil and angel in this room
ticket I don't want if you don't take a
hit I'm gonna call the police and I'm
gonna tell them that you tried to take a
hit damn girl you are you are something
you're for God
what are you gonna do with that picture
I'm gonna Master to it look I'm just
[__] with you all right damn you're a
Ted's personality
can I take another hit
it goes against a religion
and that makes you hypocrite
go ahead
they're all Hypocrites it's part of
being a sinner a human
do you find me attractive
because I'm not attracted to you at all
just so you know damn I just don't think
you're very good looking
or interesting
or intelligence very mean is this your
way of flirting you're not from your
life
there's a kid in the grade below me who
goes there he told me that they stopped
doing door-to-door stuff last year
why what is that going on what a random
plot turn Sky Jerry all he had us doing
was standing on corners and handing out
pamphlets you could just tell it you
didn't need to earn or prove his faith
at all
yeah okay
after a while I was just like am I
really
helping
maybe if you get Light One Candle I was
worried I was gonna get arrested
for smoking pot
for stealing from the mission badass
and when everyone went to sleep I
I took the petty cash how much
a hundred twenty thousand dollars two
thousand four hundred and thirty six
dollars
I thought I could use this money for my
own mission you know see my faith save
just one person so why do you keep
coming back here hoping to get money
from Charlie
so that's why you want to save my job
uh oh
Ellie
how much money did he offer you
how'd she what you think I'm an idiot
you think I would believe that you were
coming over here out of the kindness of
your heart
Charlie doesn't have any money
if you call the money from his teaching
it's been going we could have gotten you
anything you needed last winter when my
pickup broke down and I had to walk
through the snow to get your groceries
for you I offered to get your truck
fixed yeah and I refused because I
thought you had seven hundred dollars in
your bank
if there was ever any kind of emergency
I'm
with money would you I offer to fix the
truck I I don't care about you get that
through your [__] skull
damn this is
mean Ellie your your essay
it's
good essay
oh Jesus Christ try to make a stir-fry
thing yeah almost at the entire
apartment building on fire
oh my God this looks so painful
it was left raising our kids
for a man
what about us for a while you know
you know gosh she's awful
isn't she is that why you kept her for
me all this time you thought that I
would think that you're a bad mother
kinda makes you
Charlie
she's evil
she's not evil
oh what there'll be a grease fire in
hell when he starts to burn
oh that is messed up
she's a strong writer
that's your response
the only reason you married me in the
first place was to have a kid I know
that very pleased wow this is very
unpleasant
I never got to say that I was sorry
about
your friend boyfriend
you're wheezing
gotten worse
should I call someone
probably feels like he
destroys the lives of everyone he loves
we took that trip to the Oregon coast
together I went swimming in the ocean
that was the last time I ever went
swimming actually
hear the ocean waves
interesting choice to cut back to this
dance
I think you said for days after that
it's about like sea water
dying Mary
I need to know it's just gonna have a
decent life and she's gonna be okay
damn
I have to have anyone else I need to
know that I have done one thing right
with my life
do you need anything
before I leave
I really just feel like
the full-fledged history of all these
characters you know
I definitely got
temperature just blow snot into my shirt
yeah thanks Dan
have a good night okay
dad you're the MVP of this movie
does he have this pizza every night
[Music]
damn
right
nice to get a message like that
oh he's really going binging right now
it's like he's trying to end it tonight
[Music]
yep your daughter
she took these pictures of me smoking
pot and she found my church in Waterloo
somehow and then she sent it to them and
they sent it to my parents and and you
know what they said
it's just money and they want me to come
home
how awful is that
awful
you think Alan died because he chose to
be with me
yes
wow
Alan loved me he thought it was
beautiful halfway through the semester
started meeting me during my office
hours uh-huh it's perfect temperature
outside
we took a walk in the Arboretum
tests huh Alan can see what I have done
to myself Carly okay stop this is
disgusting yes I'm disgusting you're
disgusting it there you go
you found honestly Thomas it's a really
fascinating examination man
I've been replaced by someone who will
no doubt have you rewrite less authentic
less you
with every draft
Julian you wrote
sick of people telling me that I have
promised
the truth will set you free I just want
to be
honest with you too
this course doesn't matter
amazing honest things
things they matter
this movie is aggressively sad
those last few months before Alan
I'd come over here Shake him to scream
at him just trying to get him to [__]
eat something God that was awful it was
awful for me too yeah well you weren't
the one who had to identify his body all
bloated it wouldn't let me
I wasn't family
oh
I tried to save him please I thought
that if I just loved him
that he wouldn't need anywhere else
me oh
nobody could have saved him believe me I
spent years trying
I don't think I believe anyone can save
anyone only you can save yourself
she was trying to help her do you ever
get
the feeling
people are incapable
of not caring
he
people are amazing
what the [__] did you do
I need to talk to him
is she actually had to actually expect
to see her again
do you ever get the feeling that people
aren't capable about caring capable of
caring I failed
that's a really good essay I don't care
that you're dying do you want me to fail
out of high school is that why you did
this I didn't write it read it
read it I wrote this in eighth grade for
English why do you and I feel saddest of
all
boring chapters
that were only descriptions of whales oh
the author was just trying to save us
from his own sad stories
just for a little while
I wanted to know how you were doing in
school and she sent it and it's the best
dancing I've ever read
be like this
I'm sorry for leaving you
I was in love
and
I left you behind
you did not deserve that I don't I don't
know
I could have done such thing you're so
beautiful
you're amazing stop
ah
it's an Essie
miss you
you're the best thing I have ever done
you're going to the hospital
you just need surgery or something
oh God yeah you [__] kidding me oh
yeah yeah
please oh
I just named Moby Dick and which is what
in the course of the book
the pirate Ahab encounters many
hardships
this is sad because this whale doesn't
have any emotions it doesn't know how
bad AF wants to kill him he's just poor
big
animal
he said his life will be better if you
can just kill this whale but in reality
it won't help him at all
I felt saddest of all when I read the
boring chapters that were only
descriptions of whales because I knew
that the author was just trying to save
us from his own sad story
just for a little while
this book made me think about my own
life
and then it made me feel glad for men
[Music]
that's a [__] Crescendo of an editing
right there
oh
wow
I did not put that together that she had
rid of that
I feel like I should have
power it was rare word is so [__] gay
holy God
oh
man
[Music]
I just gotta sit with that for a second
oh
foreign
that was an experience all right I don't
think there's a post credit scene
yeah okay let's talk about it I'll be
right back just gonna blow my nose okie
dokie okie dokie
right
[Laughter]
I'm pretty sure
quite a few times on this channel and
I'm pretty sure this is the first time
I've seen a movie where
just like
that that fight I don't know I could be
blanking on it but like that final few
moments are just like wow this is like
husky
damn
uh that was uh that was that was crazy
well all right not really knowing much
about it other than all the talk about
Brendan Fraser is amazing in this film
and it's so sad
and I I found the experience interesting
because
all right Greg time to focus it's time
to get your thoughts in order after that
I found the experience interesting
because you know I didn't know what I
was really walking into other it's there
like someone's saying it's so sad I'm
like well it's Darren Aronofsky his [__]
tends to be pretty sad I really love
like Darren aronofsky's work I think
it's very striking I find Black Swan to
be one of the best horror movies I've
ever seen I even like uh a lot of his
most uh divisive movies I I first joint
mother and I I like I like pretty much
most things that I I've seen from him
and I know uh you know Christianity and
inclusion is often a Common Thread and
this was one of those things where it
kind of starts off in a very
melancholic seems like too light of a
word
it's harsh
it's like a harsh World Of This Moment
In Time
uh quite aggressively right away
and normally
I haven't seen the fountain though that
popped up on my I still haven't seen the
fountain uh but when
when uh when a movie becomes like so
much like that like
you know I liken it to what I call the
the student film syndrome or the short
film syndrome was like look how freaking
dramatic we are look how sad we are to
the point where it becomes ineffective
because it just feels like that's what
they're they're going for but the
performances are so strong and it was
the moments it wasn't really like this
stuff when I would like especially when
I get like choked up or cry or something
it wasn't really
the stuff where it was just going
you know be sad be sad or something like
that because because it was it was
getting to the it was sometimes linger
in in aspects of that where I found
myself kind of thinking in my head am I
gonna end up liking this movie is this
gonna feel monotonous is it gonna feel
I don't know if the right word is
pretentious but is it gonna feel forced
right and
whenever it was layered once the movie
really started to click with me I don't
exactly know what point it was but there
was a point where I started to under
really feel like I was understanding who
the characters were at least my
interpretation of it you know this is
the kind of movie I imagine there's some
really great think pieces on and
dissection of the characters because
there are fully realized characters
every character here is is very much
fleshed out and you really get a sense
for their background and it was stuff
where because pain is like what this
whole canvas is painted with the pain
it was Winter honed in on
not
not like why the pain is there and
you know I thought I didn't know if it
was going to be a movie about
like a movie that's about body
dysmorphia a movie about obesity you
know like that's that's an aspect
obviously but it's but it's like he has
become this
physical embodiment
uh
of of his pain you know that that is
what he represents
as as this person as this very obese
struggling person who's like on the
verge of death is accepting the fact
that he's going to die
he
it's like he shapes himself into that
you know
and I I didn't know if it would just be
because a lot of these characters have
these habits uh of and what I mean by
why like why the pain the specifically
the word why why the pain
why that hit me so hard excuse me guys
I'm just coming off a crime session
trying to get my thoughts perfectly
aligned here
why that hit me so hard is because you
would see that there was so much love
and that love led to so much hurt
and you really got that sense with this
Charlie character especially him but you
could see that with the even with the
the wife and Sadie sink and the Ellie
character you could see that there was
probably a point in time where their
Foundation even before they did the
flashbacks on the beach or whatever
there was probably this point in time
where
they were really happy you know and he
and he probably did love them but just
didn't love her the wife how
you could tell he still had a love for
her but just wasn't in love with her
because he was really gay
and then the path to being in love with
this Allen guy and and
what that did for Alan being part of
this church I can imagine this movie you
could offend some people especially with
religious this movie does not do do this
is what I'm gonna do it a little bit
later if there's one criticism I have
about the writing of it it has to do
with the real I'm not religious
whatsoever but there is there is a
criticism I have in terms of how the
religion aspects are sort of handled
here
regardless of what that feeds into the
character of he just wanted he's like
maybe I can
save this guy by just giving him you
know uh overwhelming flow of love
and he died and he just blames himself
you know
and
while these characters often when [__]
gets too hard they will escape via
rather storming out or resorting to
anger he resorts to binge eating you
know it is a form of physically harming
yourself and
I've I've never I've been in situations
like that where I just want to eat my
pain away I did that for a very long
time and I gained the like massive
amounts of weight and there would be
sessions
where like every Saturday I just
end up throwing up just because I would
just eat until I threw up and it
it's a sad way of living in and and I
appreciate the movie
portrays it in a way that's not trying
to make it about that
but it also is kind of about that
because really it's about who these
people are it's it is it is a human
experience it is a human journey of
everyone here and how
yes there's a lot of trauma that keeps
these people bonded together but there's
also it's also rooted in a lot of love
and when you have that quality kind of
shine through because I could see
I could see how there could be a lot of
people probably don't like this movie
too because
I feel like it could register as
I don't know what the right words misery
porn but I'm gonna go with that I see I
could see how it could register as that
versus like look how artistically
depressing this [__] is nah man when you
got that that's why that Crescendo was
so beautiful to me like God damn that
poem he that essay he keeps reciting uh
throughout the whole film and
how you know he's just saying that he
just wants to hear it before he dies and
he's just [__] [__] triple and he
just wants to make his daughter happy
that's all he cares about and that's
that's been consistent with him
throughout his whole life it wasn't like
he's been ignoring her he's wanted to be
in contact with her he saved up all the
money like it's it's been a focus of him
of his entire life and
it's it's also a Journey about
everyone learning to just be honest with
themselves and being honest with
everyone else you know like that level
of honesty of coming to terms with the
truth
EV how do we really feel underneath like
it's a movie about emotions while
there's a lot of dialogue parts that can
feel repetitive and whatnot
at the end of the day the the movie is
uh the story is about emotions the story
is about being very honest with it's
kind of like inside out but on a very
adult level it's very it's so much about
just
okay yeah you got you you put this on
display you you take out you take you
take out all your pain on your body like
this
you're a drinker he's a binge eater he's
led to obesity he's got all these health
problems
Ellie's doing everything Ellie does Liz
is very Stern and built up like like she
goes into the aggressive route as well
but you got a sense of everyone's
backstory and so over time as you peel
back these layers by the end you just
get to everyone's true emotions and the
movie even had me going with Ellie
it honestly reached the point
because at first
it wasn't until
it was when she sent the letters the the
when you find it because you're like
okay she's gonna do something with this
recording and stuff is when she sent the
recording off to Thomas's family
and you know preceding that the mom was
going
uh like she's evil you know it's like no
one to me is born evil it's
usually some form of conditioning right
and like I don't think she was evil what
she was doing but she didn't seem like a
great person and I I did
when it reached that point of
did she do that to hurt Thomas or to
help Thomas
I was here going
I feel like she might have been trying
to hurt him like that's what the move
that's what I had been sold on where
prior to that prior to the whole like
ambient and all that and and the
recording of Thomas I was really under
the impression like you know what yeah
she's she's got a [__] attitude but but
really she loves her dad and like that
was very obvious but I never I didn't
really imagine would get a scene where
as I had I had thought that she wasn't
going to come back into the movie
actually I I really thought for some
reason that she just wasn't going to
come back maybe you did and you're
smarter than me whatever I didn't think
she was gonna come back I kind of forgot
about it I didn't forget I just didn't
come back so when
when she did come back and then you see
like oh the the essay is what she wrote
this beautiful essay and this is how
oh it's so that's so smart like it makes
the whole journey worth it I I honestly
think those last few minutes make the
whole journey worth it
and
um
what was I talking about
sorry what time is it
it is it is literally 12 55 at the four
degree out of watching this movie so
it's just such a red it was such a
random night for me
becoming delusional
the
uh this stays in the video me try to
remember what I'm talking about
um yeah yeah uh with with aliens
everyone's being honest you find out why
everyone is the way they are I don't
remember what I was exactly talking
about whatever this is all state I don't
know I don't care this is gonna be raw I
like the whale's emotions and Sadie's
sink whoa holy everyone can act so well
that's what I was trying to say is that
I had the movie was selling me so much
on I actually don't even know if this is
how the girl's gonna if the movie's
gonna end on a note with uh yeah as you
might have just been a [__] uh but no
she like like she was too far gone from
the pain and the trauma she experienced
it was too far gone and there was
there's that she wasn't gonna ever turn
to being dabbing a resolve like Sadie's
sink was phenomenal in this movie is she
nominated
are the nominations out I miss I mean
yeah I know they are is Sadie Singh
nominated for this film because she's so
good
nominated for an Oscar
I guess not
damn
I mean I don't know who else was told to
do this I'm not gonna be like what the
hell why this person I don't know who
else was nominated she was phenomenal I
like her scenes with Brendan Fraser were
so were so real and believable and
layered
um talk about Nuance my God
that was so effective
I loved it loved the I loved their
dynamic
there were times where there's something
about the Thomas character that's my one
criticism about the movie
that just
out of all the pieces for some reason he
was the only part that I wasn't
it was the only part of the movie that I
found myself
constantly walking a line with of is
this working for me or is this not
working for me and I don't think it
there's a lot of things like that it did
Sir for the the bigger purpose of of the
narrative that undoubtedly yeah and
especially with the backstory with Liz
who by the way amazing is is she a funny
woman or something like that is she like
a comedian lady I remember her in the
menu uh and she was excellent in that
too but uh I've never seen her worth to
this degree she was she was phenomenal
absolutely phenomenal
what's that actress's name let me find
it for you guys
Hong Chow
I don't know her work
or maybe I do and I just forget but yeah
she's uh
she was excellent
uh
yeah another beautiful performer there
um because I did the pizza
yeah what would it keep my God okay yeah
you know it's been it's been a little
bit of a 13-hour day no no no I know I
tend to uh zigzag in a conversation on
these reviews post reaction but it's
especially gonna go down tonight and I'm
keeping it all here
um
yeah with Thomas
Ty Simpkins while I think the performer
Ty Simpkins did a really good job
the
while I'm not a religious person
I did think that there wasn't much given
to this
it started to work for me once you find
once you find out what the hell is
really going on with this guy and why
he's really here uh like everything that
Ellie ends up finding out that that's
when the it's I was like okay this is
this dramatic shift is actually making
this click for me more it's because most
of his lines pretty much just felt like
America's got totally God put me here
for a reason you got to find God like it
just never got deeper than that and it
it didn't become like it never became
thought provoking anything that he was
pitching or saying I could feel the
whoever wrote the because I imagine that
this is a very faithful play did Samuel
D Hunter who wrote this movie also write
the the play I could feel the thought
process of of the the writer uh
implementing his views on religion
and you know like I don't want to offend
anyone here I really really not a fan
because I'm I'm the kind of individual
who's like well I'm not real I grew up
Catholic I have a lot of my own reasons
of why I'm not religious now
um I still think that I've I know a good
amount of people who do have faith
whether it be Christian Mormon
Catholicism Judaism
I know a good amount of people and if it
works for them and I see that like you
know what you're a good person and uh
and I can I can still be myself around
you and I feel like really comfortable
all around you like I I love you you're
great so I don't want a dog uh I don't
want a dog religion Dogma I don't want I
don't want a dog religion
um
this movie I thought like yeah you know
there are I have no reasons too for why
I'm not a religious person and I I so I
while I don't subscribe to any faith
it did feel like I was hearing a lot of
those The Writer's voice just imposing
it and not really giving any Nuance to
uh Thomas's reasoning for God or belief
or or other [__] to say to char like it
never became like a real debate or
conversation about it you know it just
kind of felt like the same repetitive
dialogue then they like assholed himself
up by the end like that that last scene
that he had with him like oh dude dick
move
I know he had good intent to put in you
know
bad maneuver there so yeah that that was
the one quality of the movie that
I I understand like the purpose it
serves thematically for the characters
and and for the movie as a whole I did
think you know even if it is extremely
faithful to the play that it it could
have it could have used some enhancement
as opposed to just
the ones who are going to have the
biggest amount of of of uh expansion on
reasoning and debate is going to be all
the characters who are opposed against
the religion
but the one who is just keeps showing up
to want to instill the faith is it's
never like a compelling argument
like I know this is that it's not a
Netflix this is not a Netflix series
it's a movie but I think a great example
of one that does it is um midnight mass
Mike Flanagan show
the the priest on that show like when he
does a sermon
uh I don't remember what episode it was
but I was like you know what I follow
this guy I become religious
I was in the room screw it I'm cool I'm
going full Catholic right now
and not that it needed to reach that
level I just think you could have used a
little bit of peppering of that is all
I'm getting and then I think I I would
have just been fully immersed in it but
yeah no this was a miserable experience
in a lot of ways but what are those one
of those that I was I was just full I I
did I did get lost in and you know it's
it
as much as uh in the beginning it was
like this definitely feels like a play
uh it began to really evolve into feel
like a film like and I mean I mean that
in a really complimentary way like there
are certain movies I watch where I just
feel like I was watching a play and
and sometimes it's not complementary
like sometimes you gotta you gotta fuse
the worlds I think when you translate uh
play to film like like Glenn Ross is an
amazing job at that from as being a film
uh fences while beautifully acted I
really felt like I was just watching a
stage flame they were cutting back
between the same three shots where here
you still have a nice great use of
cinematography
um atmosphere you could feel the
isolation yet you get a sense of like
just beyond the door is the outside
world where he's never gonna go to
eeo what's the wildlife Erin obstacle
bringing some of his visual like I felt
like the ending especially with him like
raising up you know
dying with acceptance and peace and
happiness getting that relief
that felt very aronofsky-like and even
the use of the flashback uh on the on
the beach felt very aeronofsky so having
some of those like film language visual
flourishes I thought was great I thought
there was amazing music in here
uh the Liz character I really like the
dynamic between them because you don't
really see a dynamic like that in film
and uh I thought that
her
she just feels like people I've met like
she really does she really feels like
people I've met
where
it was also cool about her
it's nice to get like an I don't think
they did they don't ever make mention of
the fact that she is actually Asian huh
as a Filipino it makes me happy to see
her in fact that she's a nurse I think
she's a nurse I might just protect you
um but the fact that she's Asian and
they don't make it a thing that she's
Asian
I'm pretty sure they don't they're more
kudos to that
but the dynamic of you were the best
thing that happened to my brother and I
loved you for who you were when my
brother was around and now I must
protect you too and look after you as
well it's a very fascinating Dynamic and
again you could really feel you could
feel like these actors all fleshed out
the history that's like that's what you
want from these performances
is
you don't need to say much but whenever
you guys are talking like I can tell
that all you guys know all the memories
more than what's being said on screen or
even into that like you guys really know
your memories
and yeah
I haven't really touched much on him
Brendan Fraser
I saved it for the end when most people
have already clicked off this video
Brendan Fraser is
peace
Beyond exceptional
he's astronomical in this film
I thought I'd be watching a movie where
I just kept going Brendan Fraser doing
great you know where I'm just aware I'm
watching Brendan Fraser the whole time
and like look at Brendan Fraser acting
he became this guy
hands down the best performance he's
ever done
hands down
he was just this dude you know and
he he wasn't like ever
it's like a heavy per no but it said
it's like a heavy performance it is and
what I respected so much about it was
it did feel like I was looking at
someone's life on screen because I'm not
even talking about how it correlates
with Brendan Fraser the actor or
something like that I I'm talking about
how
you know they had that thing in there
where he tries to be optimistic and he
tries to find the positive spin when
clearly this guy is in a world of his
own misery and it's just utterly
depressed
he he carried this
it felt authentic just so the word that
comes to mind is sincerity it's it's
genuine that
that uh
that tenderness towards others that that
interesting care and and and the power
of the language and the and embracing
the honesty and like the love that he
has you can really feel it
just embroiled in
so much
so much shame and lack of self-worth
there's like no self like so much love
exerted but no but no self-love
you know like even when he talks about
Alan and Thomas or he's getting
defensive he's like I was never remember
the best looking guy in the room but he
thought I was beautiful like even then
before he even became this like shape
that he becomes
even then you get the idea that this guy
never never really had self-love did he
as much as he could find it elsewhere as
much as you can find love he never had
it for himself
it was such a fully realized performance
it was
painstakingly beautiful who's he up
against
I want to know who's up against
yeah oh boy you deserve some awards
um
Oscar nominations 2033
oh you're going up against Austin Butler
you did become Elvis for like five years
foreign
Fraser still deserves it
I've seen both of these movies and uh
yeah I think Brandon Frazier deserves it
I'm saying that right now
[Laughter]
anyway guys
awesome Butler will get another chance
the guy's like five years old he go get
another chance
let Brendan Fraser have it
and
Austin Butler can go up on stage and
slap him
ladies and gentlemen what did you think
of the whale did you enjoy it I guess
I'd give it like a
8 out of ten yeah yeah I'm confident
with that like an eight out of 10.
alrighty well
I had to jump like an 8.5 like the
acting it's just two two two two minutes
not my favorite Airline like not by not
by a long shot but uh
it's it's still
it's it is very moving and that ending
that ending like really made the whole
thing
like really sing for me oh the person
plays wife also incredible incredible
she has like one scene in this movie
like she showed up he she did her
homework she was great and that again I
appreciate the I appreciate how it's not
just people screaming at each other that
they would you could see that it was all
at the end of the day
all whatever anger frustrations there's
always rooted in
in love
anyway reject Nation
dig deeper in your emotions and and if
you're in pain or you find yourself in a
stress or angry State sometimes I gotta
do that sometimes I'm like just kind of
like I do these exercises
because I can be a very emotional guy I
do these exercises where I close my eyes
and I'll just start saying how I feel
like just very subconscious very stream
of Consciousness and I'll just find my
face doing this
why do I feel angry angry is usually a
sign that I'm hurt am I feeling hurt by
something what am I hurt by like I gotta
like dissect it a little bit so I
encourage the same thing too
alrighty I'm gonna try to edit this
other movie reaction first to round to
it but thank you for being here